salut scène ce groupe bienvenue sur une
scène spécialement dédié aux hommes et
aussi un peu aux femmes sur cette chaîne
qui va trouver du contenu que tu n'auras
jamais vu ailleurs toutes les questions
que tu t'es posées et auxquelles tu n'as
jamais eu de réponse ici on parle de la
vie des hommes et rien de la vie des
hommes
une chaîne 100% masculine et qui sent
bon la testostérone
on va parler couple séduction sexe mode
cuisine cuisine pour ovins high tech et
développe et tout ça spécialement pour
les mecs
alors si tu veux être le meilleur et
bien plus encore à beaune toi et en plus
de ça il y aura même des cadeaux à
gagner
alors qu'est ce que tu attends